[Musique]
mais la vie si toucan est astucieux bell
bell
c'est le plus sérieux à jouer
c'est devenu un ami
hajduk encore oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya un
an je suis énervé je suis énervé parce
que là j'ai préparé pour nos amis une
expérience qui n'est pas facile à
réaliser
là c'est pour ça que tu as amené cette
bassine oui alors nous avons une bassine
pleine d'eau vous pouvez le faire chez
vous sans problème bien sûr attend rien
je veux rien à petit tout à ne pas
s'approcher je ne voulais pas dire est
que ce nouvel iphone
alors regardez bien j'ai pris des
bouchons de bouteille et où ces bouchons
sont ici sur la table et je vais vous
montrer que ces bouchons peuvent se
séparer ou ils ne sont pas sont pas
collés du tout et c'est bon voilà
comment se présentent les bouchons alors
vous les mettez en tas comme ceci bon il
faut qu'il soit verticaux sais pas vous
allez plonger directement dans l'eau
comme ça tu vas pas les faire tenir dans
l'eau comme ça et bien si justement tout
le problème consiste à faire tenir les
bouchons comme cela dans l'eau avec
normalement un bouchon sa flotte
par conséquent ils devraient tous
éparpillés mais si on prend bien soin de
les serrer comme ça dès le départ
regardez bien ce que vous pourrez
montrer ça à vos parents ce soir ils
sont vraiment épaté je voudrais le voir
pour le croire et à regarde je le plonge
au fond de la bassine tous les bouchons
ensemble et puis normalement
si je réussis ce que je dois faire en
laissant remonter les bouchons tout
doucement et vous je les laisse remonter
comme ça il devrait tenir ensemble sur
l'eau et voilà extraordinaire ça c'est
extraordinaire
regarde qui put rencontre bien qui tous
il est fort fabrice rendre et bien mes
enfants je n'en reviens pas moi-même on
french ap ap oui oui ça sent pas bon
c'est formidable à fabriquer maladie
comme tout bon et aux rebelles notamment
au fait le mot thème allez je vais au
mot tabou matin c'était formidable ça
comme truc
bon alors le mot à mot je vous rappelle
brièvement comment se passent les choses
dans le mot à mot nous allons avoir un
certain nombre de carton sur lequel vous
verrez des dessins ses dessins
représentent des syllabes ou si vous
préférez des parties de mots et avec ses
différentes syllabes
nous allons essayer de former un mot
complet moi je vais tâcher d'en faire un
très long oui bah c'est pas facile c'est
pas facile ça m'étonnerait tu vas voir
rapidos ça devrait marcher très bien à
lyon tu tires cinq cartes je tire 5/4
seulement alors je commence avec ceux ci
qui est un un mur nous sommes d'accord
ça c'est un mur ça tout cas encore
d'après toi c'est quoi ça sauf si tu as
un sac
c'est un sac très bien enfin là nous
avons 1
là nous avons ça c'est de la com on a
reconnu de l'aïe a réduit mais non mais
non une hache bon alors on réfléchit
quelques pour juni du tas unités du
rapido oui j'ai toujours eu trois nuls
auj nulle haye formidable mais oui bien
sûr me
et puis haye pardon murail
voilà assez bien joué et c'est ce qui va
les bouffer rapido alors je vais écrire
muraille
il est très fort un oui il a été très
rapide en plus c'est parce qu'il rase
souvent les murailles hausse est
possible ça voilà vide on regarde bien
un pouce moussu parce que muraille tu ne
sais pas l'écrire noir
oui j'ai toujours des fautes
d'orthographe rihaoui murail voilà
fabrice dis donc tu vais retirer
d'autres cartons oui parce qu'on ne veut
plus rien à faire avec ça ne rien de bon
là je tire allez vous prendre celui là
un des espaces à reprendre le d et c'est
une scie voilà une scie et voilà le d
alors ou entités où j'y trouvais qu
est-ce qui agit quelque chose
mais qu'est ce que tu as trouvé aussi un
bon mot trois syllabes didon quoi eux d
un nom un d'abord un alors un oui oui le
d t il assis un décès ben ça c'est bien
joué tout cas encore oui bravo indécis
merci regarde comme ça et si c'est bien
jouer il fallait y penser
ce n'était pas si simple indécis bravo
c'est bien jouer si bien qu'ottawa oui
ça je te félicite tu as été très fort
tout cas encore bravo bon petit alors
c'est moi qui vais pouvoir envoyer le
petit souvenir non d'abord je voudrais
vous signaler que nous avons reçu
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de lettres ce
dont nous vous remercions tout cas
encore rapido c'est fou ce motion était
très content et parmi toutes ces lettres
nous en avons trouvé une que nous avons
particulièrement aimé car il ya un
dessin qui nous représente et oui c'est
un dessin charmant je vous montrais si
vous le voulez bien
c'est une lettre qui nous vient
2 claude jean françois et marie laure
berg et nous dit des petites choses très
très sympathique et voici le dessin vous
allez voir que c'est vraiment l'émission
c'est vraiment nous un élite regarder
tout ça c'est formidable à six têtes et
intérêts la rapide hausse il ya tout le
monde vous êtes vous toujours dessiné un
bravo et merci à d'autre part on nous
demande également si il y à le disque
des quatre amis d'un oui il existe
parfaitement vous pouvez le trouver chez
votre disquaire
le voilà et c'est un disque que nous
avons enregistré tous ensemble et que
vous pourrez entendre voilà chez votre
disquaire
vous le trouverez voilà qui est fait
absolument abscon fabrice ça va être à
nous maintenant un poussin sud
la ville va tu t'es bien préparé oui
allez j'y vais je crois je crois alors
que me proposes tu alors je te propose
de deviner un mot en neuf lettres en
neuf lettres neuf lettres
oui c'est un mot qui commence par là la
première lettre c'est un fils et il
était là il a bu le tableau là est un
peu de travail oui et c'est plus grave
alors 1 sec mais assez assez voilà c'est
très bien et alors la dernière un thé
alors combien de lettres un thé dont
combien de l'étrange combien à bâcher 10
ans neuf lettres en neuf alors je fais
cette traite petites rêveries cette
étudiante et un ppri alors voilà bon
alors est-ce que tu continues les moyens
de transport ah non non non alors pas du
tout menacé cette semaine j'ai changé
qu'est-ce que tu pries ayala c'est
quelque chose qui se mange ça se mange
oui ça se mange
alors est ce qu est ce que c est ce que
c'est de la viande non non pas de la
viande est ce que c'est un fruit
la sepaq com ses paris est ce que c'est
un légume non plus c'est pas légumes un
dessert agissent à ça peut être à
dessein j'adore les desserts asus et
acer je les plains des services je suis
cela donne une petite led
supplémentaires pour aider oui si tu
veux alors là la deuxième lettre c'est
un achat la deuxième lettre c'est un
achoui dit
on sait alors là c'est facile de croire
attends attends attends est ce que ces
marrons bah oui c'est un gros oui oui tu
permets une seconde lui ai dit tu vas
bien dix neuf lettres un oeuf lait cuit
bah c'est pas possible enfin comment tu
vas me dire tu as pensé à chocolat mais
si exactement championnat su comme en
écriture chocolat da costa se prononcer
ch a eu ses hauts l athée mais enfin mon
pauvre pouces moussu mais tu est la
risée de tous jeunes ou regarder mes
chocolats ça s'écrit c'est à chaud enfin
ch11 colette9 riches comme ça c'est pas
parce qu'un jour on dit toujours un
chocolat bien chaud alors que cinquième
à mort ah bon on peut avoir un bon
chocolat chaud mais chocolat c'est à
chaud ah bon ben voilà ce que tu dis je
te plains c'est que c'est vrai c'est
vrai aussi que le chocolat il faut pas
en abuser
attention c'était en petite quantité
c'est très nourrissant ça donne beaucoup
de force pour des ratons pas en abuser
c'est vrai qu'est ce que tu voulais dire
que je jouais je viens d'apercevoir bbb
à bb la barre mais on va aller la
retrouver voilà rejoint ruraux mais les
larges pouvoirs
[Musique]
sg aujourd'hui delta et bien aujourd'hui
moche à fabrice j'ai envie de te
proposer un nouveau chai musical aux
mêmes très musical puisque je vais te
demander de reconnaître un instrument de
musique dont je vais te faire entendre
le son à ça j'adore ça oui débat moi
j'ai une petite place oui alors j'appuie
sur un bouton oui et écoute biya voilà
[Musique]
alors quel est cet instrument écoute je
crois que j'ai deviné quand même c'est
un instrument à cordes nous sommes bien
d'accord oui ça fait des semaines ou
trois qui jeta c'est un instrument
accord c'est l'instrument je crois le
plus aigu des cordes oui donc ce doit
être le violon et mais c'est parfait
c'est le plus petit de la famille des
cordes
c'est vrai parce qu'un à de très très
gros si mais nous verrons peut-être sa
plus tard et je t'ai fait une surprise
que je devais me garde de la bête
ici la boulette qui est là sur la chaire
attends attends attends des vides
or je crois que j'ai deviné d'accord et
nous a mis aussi je prends mais je crois
que c'était facile
oui ce n'est pas très difficile il
s'agit d'un violon le voilà ce violon
haye vous voyez que c'est un très très
bel instrument à il y en a de très
anciens de très très très beau et très
coûteux aussi oui ça il est en bois
comme vous pouvez le voir la vie des
civils les chiffres sur les suppléments
je ne le serai pas faire parce que c'est
très fragile
les trajets abri silva des cuirs le
violon pour nos petits amis
vous avez quatre cordes sur ce violon je
vais les faire sonner voyez vous
[Musique]
on n'est pas très bien accordé c'est
vrai enfin au moins vous l'entendez et
pour jouer que dis-tu hong quan entend
très bien et pour jouer du violon il
faut un archet le voici sept archet vous
voyez la partie blanche qui est du crin
de cheval ça c'est amusant franchement
il faut avoir une drôle d'idée d'aller
chercher le cra sur le cheval et ça
c'est faire des censures un violent et
pour accrocher les cordes
on met de la colophane une espèce de
résine dur que l'on met sur le crains et
ça accroche alors vous venez ça fait des
sauts
bien entendu on ne le portent pas comme
ça on joue du violon dans cette position
comme ceci est en jeu concert c'est pas
mal mais si tu veux je vais te faire
entendre quelqu'un qui joue beaucoup
mieux que toi n'ont pas de mal alors je
vais appuyer sur un petit bouton oui
alors tu es prêt je suis pas je tiens
toi bien parce que ça c'est autre chose
que ce que tu joues un voilà alors ma
petite boîte tu marches l'union allons-y
vas-y
[Musique]
quelle classe non voilà ce qu'on peut
faire quand on sait jouer effectué bravo
belle belle c'est bien choisis qui
aimerait être chef d'orchestre howie
c'est un merveilleux métier
dis-donc pouces ce violon parce que
c'est très fragile et j'ai peur que la
bim s'il te plaît fanon javel à mener
pour chanter le générique avec toi on va
croire je joue du violon tu viens
chanter notre petitesse j'arrive à me
déranger
bizarre les quatre étapes de la vie j'ai
chanté des chansons mais comme jenny pas
de baignoire lèveront cap et attention
les tables sa part a dit les miens ça me
sens heureux car il aime la vie
d'accord est ce que je veux
[Musique]
j'invite pas joué aujourd'hui a dit
vouloir devenir un ami
[Musique]
il alluma prix